one of the things that happened when i
did the first ghostbusters it came out
it was such a big hit
and um i used to get invited to come to
schools and talk to the kids
and uh and i would go there and i'd make
a monterey ghostbusters you jump
um nice and the teachers liked it
because the kids would play ghostbusters
but they wouldn't fight each other they
would chase the imaginary ghosts and
trap him and all that
so uh but one of the things that kids
would answer at first it confused me
because the kids would
they would say where does winston go
and i'm like where does winston go and
he said yeah where does winston go
because
he was in he was there with with the
other ghostbusters then he left
where did he go home where is his home
you know does he is he married does he
have kids we don't know
a damn thing about winston where's bill
murray we kind of see him in his you
know his little
studio or danny in his little lab or
or you know we get a sense of
you know what is outside of what we're
seeing but with winston he's just
there he just pumps up and um
so that's um that's it's
frustrating that's changed a lot um but
in the meantime
you know you have to keep you know keep
working hopefully you can bring
something
but i will say and a lot of people would
not like him to say this
you